more than 91 000 classified military
records relating to the war in
afghanistan
julian assange talks to reporters about
the release of the documents spanning
six years
he also discusses unreported incidents
of afghan civilian killings
and covert operations against the
taliban contained in the reports
the guardian from this morning 14
14 pages about this topic
also concurrently in the spiegel 17
pages
the new york times i'm not sure how many
international herald tribune
and i believe the telegraph also has it
on front page i haven't
checked into the others what do you say
when
people like the white house accuse you
of compromising the security of troops
in
afghanistan by virtue of this massive
lead
we're familiar with
groups whose abuse we expose attempting
to criticize the messenger
to distract from the power of the
message
and we don't see any difference
in the white house's response to this
case
to the other groups that we have exposed
we have tried hard to make sure that
this material does not
put innocence at harm all the material
is over seven months old so is of no
current operational consequence even
though it may be of
very significant investigative uh
consequence
um i'm curious as to
whether you feel at risk at all or under
threat i think here in the uk
as a result of this
from time to time we have threat
warnings from
our sources and
people in a position to know in
government and
some national security reporters we take
those seriously
in the west
we haven't felt a threat to our personal
safety
in kenya and other parts of the
developing world unfortunately that has
not always been true
we do have surveillance events from time
to time and there have been more in the
past
few months we understand
from the work of a national security
reporter in australia that the
australian government
was asked by the united states
to engage in certain forms of
surveillance of my person and
other wikileaks people in australia
that source says most of uh those
requests were rejected
by the australian government what do you
think this does to the
state today with the uk us and other
nato
allies
i think it's too early to say yet it's
clear that
it will shape an understanding of what
the past six years of war has been like
uh and that the course of the war
needs to change the manner in which it
needs to change is not yet clear
i'm often asked this question what is
the most
single damning revelation what is the
thing that is
easily capturable the single event the
single personality
the single mass killing uh but that is
not the real story of this material
the real story of this material is that
it's war
it's one damn thing after another
it is the continuous small events
the continuous deaths of
children insurgents
allied forces the maimed people
search for the word amputation in this
material
or amputee and there are dozens and
dozens of references
so this is the story of the war
since 2004 and like
most of the accidents that occur on the
road are as a result
of cars not of buses
most of the deaths in this war are
as a result of the everyday squalor of
war
not the big incidences that said of
course
there are reports with high kill counts
in this material for example a single
report
taking place in on august the 9th
2006 has a kill count of 181
one wounded one
one wounded zero detained
what is the circumstance behind that
report well it's part of operation
medusa
but the full circumstance is not yet
known according to the report
an ac-130 gunship is a cargo plane which
has been fitted out with cannons all
along one side
circled around for three hours and
killed 62 of those people
we add up all those deaths in that
report we get about 80.
the deaths of the other 100 are still
unexplained
there are many reports like that it
looks
look very suspicious but the full
details are not yet explained
we can see the behavior of task force
373 a special forces
assassination squad a kill or capture
squad
involved in pursuing
the jpel the joint priority effects list
a euphemism for the u.s
assassination list killer capture list
in afghanistan there are many events
associated with that
some that uh resulted in the deaths of
um one that results in the deaths of
seven children
and others that result in the deaths of
a number of other innocents
uh for that for that list we can also
see how people get on the list
they seem to be recommended by regional
governors in afghanistan or by
intelligence authorities often with it
appears little evidence and of course no
judicial review
journalistic story that we managed to
pull together these four groups
sunshine press wikileaks the spiegel
new york times and the guardian
to share investigative resources we
shared research stemming out of this
material
not final stories but research and
computational techniques to deal with
this material
as equal partners with the
exception that we controlled the embargo
date and could move that
back and forth
we i spoke to
nick davies of the guardian
who was instrumental in starting
to broker that arrangement and then we
did it at an editor-editor basis
between the uh alan rostrigger and the
editor of the spiegel
and the editor of new york times that's
a very quick question
um the mod
this morning are saying that even they
aren't able to verify
much of these documents i'm sure the us
would probably say the same about other
documents too at this stage
how can you be sure that what's placed
up on the internet is accurate and if
some of it is not
doesn't that eat into your legitimacy
wikileaks because it's wrong information
and therefore it's up there
if some of that information was
inaccurate
uh that wouldn't eat into our legitimacy
quite correct
however we have never released
misdescribed material and i don't expect
this case to be any exception
some people are suggesting that lots of
the intelligence or some of the
intelligence
it's difficult to quantify came from low
level
came from people who are biased against
different absolutely and so how can you
rely on that how can you allow people to
read
information and placed up there as if it
were truths
as far as you're concerned when we
publish material
what we say is the document
as we describe it is true
we publish cia reports all the time
that our legitimate cia reports that
doesn't mean
the cia is telling the truth
similarly with this material
there is reporting from military units
of various kinds
in afghanistan reporting from u.s
embassies
across the world about matters relevant
to afghanistan
reporting from informers in
pakistan and afghanistan
those are legitimate reports it doesn't
mean
that the contents are true some people
should exercise caution
people should exercise caution and i'll
give you some examples of the ways in
which they should exercise caution
and we in fact do this if you go to war
diary dot wikileaks dot org you will see
how how to read the material report
you will find that u.s military units
when
self-reporting of course
often speak in ex-corporate language
redefine civilian casualties as
insurgent
casualties downplay the number of
casualties
and we know this by looking comparing
these reports to
the public record for where there has
been comprehensive investigations so as
an example
kunduz gorani for the kunduz report
we see that the initial
report from the field was 56
insurgents killed no civilians killed
but we know from later reportage
investigation in fact
most of the people killed were civilians
and there was some hundred and something
but when units report when military
units report on other military units
they are more likely to be frank
on other u.s military units when they
report
on other allied units that are not from
the u.s military for example on the
poles or on the brits
they are even more likely to tell the
truth
and of course when they are reporting on
the taliban
then all the evil comes out
similarly when we look at reporting from
informers we can see
sometimes completely outlandish claims
they just don't hold water
it will sometimes say that that
reporting is the result of the source
being paid it will sometimes
there is a rating system that uh marines
intelligence
will give these sources how reliable
they think they are
so that is the opinion of marines
intelligence as the
marines g2 intelligence how reliable the
source is and
how much you should take away from it
but
just like dealing with any source you
should
exercise some common sense uh that
doesn't mean
uh you should close your eyes what have
you learned about the germans
um what are the statements the white
house made immediately with regards to
pakistani links
um the guidance was you've been sent and
says i don't think anyone who follows
this issue will find it surprising
i suppose that's what i found about this
whole thing but
the detail is stunning in the nike 1000
documents or something
and yet in the end there is so much that
one doesn't find entirely surprising i
wonder if
you've concluded that at the end of all
this i'm following on from my colleague
about reliability
do you find it in any way suspicious
that the documents that you've
got here are all labeled secret but not
top secret
they're all fairly low level field
reports they come from junior officers
the only guy in jail
is a private first class i mean have you
again
you any feeling that perhaps
you have reason to doubt the reliability
of these governments
we have no reason to doubt the
reliability of these documents
uh we should say what they don't include
uh they don't include top secret reports
they don't include most
reports from u.s special forces
they don't include reports by the cia
they don't include reports by
other coalition partners however
they do include the majority of
regular us army activity and where
regular u.s army overlaps
in the activities of other forces in
afghanistan
it includes reports about their
activities so when
task force 373 the special forces
assassination squad
is involved in a raid it will often
partner
with regular us army forces and so there
are descriptions about
its activities similarly when the cia
is engaged in a raid or
a u.s army bomb squad needs to be called
in or something like this
you'll see oga other government agency
a sort of cover typically for the cia
sometimes for the
dia defense intelligence agency
and you can see some information about
the behavior of the cia
through this overlap with regular us
army activity
surprised by the revelations
we have a harm minimization process our
goal is just reform our method is
transparency but we do not put
the method before the goal we have a
serious endeavor we do things in policy
we do not do things in an
ad hoc way so
so far our harm minimization procedures
have always worked to our knowledge
no one has ever been physically harmed
by the material we have released
even though we have uh caused the
change of governments and many other
serious
reforms just a quick
um
i don't know enough about that policy to
to comment meaningfully
um i can only say prima facie if
uh restraints are reduced there will be
more civilian casualties
bbc um you talk about the harmonization
policies and this is only relates to the
material before
seven months ago but how do you respond
to the charge that
you're in no position to know
particularly given the vast amount of
material out there what harm is being
done to
sources or potential sources in terms of
that and also on the historical point
about it all
relating from last year how do you
respond to the
question well how do you respond to the
point that um the obama administration
would argue that actually you say things
must change that they will argue that
things have changed that this all comes
before the surge actually got into
operation
one of the interesting things that we
have noticed from this material
is that at the time that mcchrystal took
command
with a stated policy intention of
reducing
civilian casualties especially from
airstrikes
a new field appeared in these reports
a field of credible allegations
of coalition forces causing
civilian casualties
that appears to have been an attempt by
mcchrystal to get
some handle on the situation to get some
measure on where civilian casualties
were occurring
as a result of coalition activity but
what we see
is that the us army is
an enormous boat that is extremely hard
to turn around
and the cover-up of
those sorts of crimes begins at the
bottom
and moves its way to the top so it is
quite hard
to enact a new policy
and have it filtered down to a change in
practice
a new policy by obama does not mean
a change of practice by the us military
any more
the new policy by mcchrystal meant
a change in practice uh by u.s forces
so these are war crimes
sorry
all the information that you gave them
access to if they held back
what did they hold back on and do you
have more of this kind of material to
come out you spoke about
uh
wikileaks since december has been a bit
on a bit of a publishing hiatus
in order to do significant
re-engineering
to cope with the level of submissions we
were receiving and the level of
public interest in our site is actually
a very hard
engineering task to supply
two to five percent of the entire world
internet connected population at a
single moment
with material and so we're a small
organization trying to understand how to
do that and do that in a secure way
as a result we have built up during that
period
an enormous backlog of whistleblower
disclosures
additionally after the collateral murder
tape came out which revealed how two
reuters journalists were killed in 2007
in baghdad
along with 18 to 26 other people
we received a substantial increase in
the number of submissions
so now we have an enormous range of
material we are trying to get through
and trying to
keep our promise to our sources in
achieving the maximum political impact
for that material in relation to these
in particular these documents
this is one of those cases this is what
one of the cases of us getting through
our backlog
so we have released to the public
some 76 000
reports from this set of material
the set itself comprises of over 91 000
reports we have held back about 15 000
reports of a particular type to undergo
a further minimization review
and those
some of those reports will be redacted
and released
released as soon as we are able to get
through them
and others will be withheld
until the security situation in
afghanistan
means that it is safe to release them
and by safe i do not mean safe for
military forces i mean safe for the
local population of afghanistan why
don't you call somebody
these actions just now and then decline
to answer the question from my
colleagues
don't find that interesting well hang on
you're here to talk about the freedom of
expression
you're using to answer questions that's
a little hypocritical
you have your phrase your questions you
use the word crimes and now you're
refusing to explain why
you have to phrase you have to wait your
turn and you also have to praise your
questions
in a meaningful way
do we have another question do you find
that difficult
um just curious why you decided to
donate
collaboration with media outlets and as
something
we've had one video production so far so
we don't really know how to do
a tv that well we had hoped to
partner with a network to do a more
significant investigation but
limited time and resources equips that
we do hope to do that next time
the reason why these three organizations
obviously we can't have a journalistic
coalition which is too large
sharing everything equally for the
logistical reasons it just doesn't hold
um so when we're talking three or four
that we can actually
get together into a room and agree on
all the conditions
those simply are with possibly the
exception
of some french publications
the uh three
the best three research uh publications
in print
new york times the spiegel and the
guardian one of them
the investigation of the kundus event in
2005
which killed um over 100 people
and approximately 60 to 80 civilians
by the german press is an interesting
case study
because the german press investigated
this with
incredible thoroughness
that is not seen for any other single
event
in afghanistan or iraq
and it's really i suppose a credit to
the german press
to see that level of investigation but
it also speaks to some kind of market
demand or cultural desire
uh in germany to see those sort of
crimes
thoroughly uh investigated where german
forces play a part um there
there are a number of reports that do
concern german forces uh
and the regions where german forces are
stationed
including task force 373 which is
stationed
or has been stationed near a
german-controlled region
der spiegel has more on that issue
i will let them speak for me they know
more about the details
as a whole
new york the media groups including us
agreed that the new york times would
approach
the white house for comment and the
pentagon for comment
and that would comment would then come
back and be shared amongst
the others uh that approach uh took
place in the middle
of last week so they knew it at least
since that point
um we haven't uh had
any um direct attempts to censor us
like every delicate investigation we
have of course
held things close to our chest and so
have the other media organizations
what if anything do you hope to change
with the release of support changing
foreign policy
more information a higher public profile
yourself the site we give a promise to
whistleblowers that come to us that is
our role as the international public
service that provided they meet
some very simple criteria like
like a lawyer we will represent them
fairly to the court
in our case the court of public opinion
so this submission met that
criteria and therefore we were tasked
to keep our promise of getting the
maximum political impact for it
and i think we appear to be living up to
that promise
that said of course
some material calls out for more
attention
and material which exposes significant
human rights abuses
tasks us to spend more effort on it
some of those 15 000 documents i think
you were talking about earlier on
so presumably within those 15 000 or so
documents there are things that you
maybe have already seen that might
deserve some amount of attention
being the case and the fact that you get
immediate coverage whenever these things
happen
can you then therefore answer the
question that's been asked twice already
by a journalist
you mentioned the word crimes can you
please just be a bit more specific
about what you meant by are these crimes
committed within these documents
because unless the question is answered
how do you expect the media to take you
seriously down the line when there are
potentially more good stories to go what
is your specific question
you mentioned a a a while ago
war crimes or crimes when you were
talking about the documents you didn't
you weren't specific
what i'm asking you is to be more
specific when you talk about
war crimes or crimes as i think the word
you used
i think i was speaking about the issue
in general however
it is up to a court to decide
clearly whether something is in the end
a crime
that said prima facie it does appear to
be
evidence of war crimes in this material
example is the task force 373
high mars missile strike on a house
which killed
seven children
yes
on the one hand as we all know the
united kingdom
is a surveillance state on the other
hand
we do have extensive uh political
journalistic and community support in
this country
and it would only serve our
interests in fact to be
for me to be arrested or detained i i
can't imagine
uh that happening in this country um i
uh unless unless there was a
miscommunication from the bureaucracy to
the political leadership
so political leadership in this country
would not tolerate that
the um the motives of wikileaks in all
of this are
well known and you've expressed them i i
wonder without
revealing your source on this what what
your source was motives
for for releasing this material to you
um where
was it was a motive expressed to you
yeah we
when we get submissions we typically get
a statement in fact we
require usually a statement from the
source
about what they wanted us to do with the
material why it's important
and so on um so yes
the source wanted to call attention to a
number
uh of these incidents um
uh not not all the ones that we have
found but
um some of the ones that we have found
and
and their perception was of course there
would be many more and they appear to be
correct
uh yes we have uh committed funds uh
to uh mr manning's
lawyer we are he's his jag
team and they understand that those
funds are available
at the point that he wishes to choose
to engage his civilian council presently
um his
jag u.s military legal team
has not chosen uh civilian council
privilege is independent the fifteen
thousand documents you talk about have a
similar low level of the ones that
you're looking at
further are they similar uh low-level
intelligence reports or does this
include
u.s embassy papers and other documents
there are a number
there are
over 50 us embassy cables are in the
material
that has been released already
the majority of the material that has
not been
released yet are threat reports
we experience certain you know
surveillance events from time to time
um and uh
our sources have told us something of
the
decision-making process that was
occurring
some months ago within the white house
i shouldn't really say more about that
but that the private statements are made
within the white house
and state department were
concerning
however those private statements
have now synced up to the public
statements which are acceptable
mostly acceptable
yes all right one of the papers you work
with suggested that you um
have access to several million files um
which amount history of american
government
around the world and that they'd be very
controversial can you give can you
confirm that and can you give us some
flavor of why they're so controversial
we have in this backlog that we have
built up
we have files that concern
every country in the world with a
population of over one million people
including the united states
we won't go into further detail until
that material is to be released
that it is not one thing about lots of
places but rather
thousands of uh databases and files
about all sorts of countries
we're working as hard as we can
have you got a big team we have a small
team
of dedicated and overworked people
that said we also have
around 800 volunteers part-time
volunteers
and an extended network of 10 000 people
and i suppose loosely
70 000 supporters
as anyone who will know who's managed an
organization
uh going from a small organization to a
large organization is
very difficult let alone um in this
adversarial security environment that we
have to work in
easy
appears to be quite sort of big it's
getting a lot of coverage that more
people are going to
follow suit and come forward with
information are you already getting a
sense that people are approaching you
with stuff
that is our experience that courage is
contagious
that when there is a significant source
disclosure
that is resulting in a media impact and
appears
that it's going to result in some kind
of political reform down the track
sources are encouraged
by the opportunities that they see
before them and step forward so we
expect that to also be
true in this case
entering into it i hope so
yes yes we were um
mr manning is there is no allegation uh
as far as we can determine uh that this
material is connected uh to bradley
manning
uh either in these sort of chat logs and
evidence that has been
provided all as a result of the charges
that the u.s military have applied to
him
but that said he is a very high-profile
alleged source
in fact he's the only alleged uh
us military source so there is of course
a
natural media tendency to
for anything related to us governor us
military to try and
correlate this to mr manning but
as far as we can see from the public
record
there is no evidence of a correlation
yes
there are no reports
in here directly from german forces
there are some reports
by u.s forces saying what german forces
have told them and there are reports by
u.s forces
on their interactions or encounters
with german forces and others
but there are no direct reports
in this material from
any other group than of the
united states army and marines
sometimes there are reports that are
given to
regular army and marines and that are
then incorporated into this material for
example
u.s embassy cables
i'm not a cross
how do you feel about the uh
that's possible but where
publicity is based on the truth
we do not now call that propaganda
we did in the 1930s but but not anymore
that said this material
does not leave anyone um
look uh smelling like roses especially
the taliban
i mean there are some reports in here if
you add up the figures of
2 000 people civilians killed by
ieds now of course
it is wrong to say that all those ieds
were planted by the taliban but they
were
presumably planted by rebel forces of
some description
uh in afghanistan what do you think in
the end
this the disclosure of these documents
really signifies and i think you've said
that this is the
most comprehensive history of a war in
terms of the raw detail
ever to have been tested
you know what do you think that
signifies what what does it mean in the
end what will change what might change
what should change
so this is the equivalent
of opening the stazi archives
no one particular stasi file
has a tremendous impact to change a
whole nation
to change the whole nation of germany
but across
all the stasi files
many individuals are represented and
many people in german society could see
their connection
to the behavior of the stasi
so i and that's something that came out
over time
so i expect that to be the case also uh
in this material
it is the is a history it is a
enormous compendium of material that
will affect
many different people in different ways
we as a journalistic group the
poor media groups who worked on this
have really only just scratched the
surface i think between us we've
probably read
about a thousand or two thousand of
these reports properly
so it's going to take
the rest of the world press and
academics to look
at the statistics that come out of this
and the soldiers and return soldiers
from afghanistan from coalition forces
will take the taliban to look at this
the refugees from afghanistan the locals
still living there
to all look at this and say i understand
that event
i was there this is just a tiny summary
let me tell you
what really went on that was my father
who was killed that was my buddy
who was killed that was my commanding
officer who gave me an
order that i was extremely uncomfortable
with
we had we saw things like that coming
out
when we released the collateral murder
video we saw two
two u.s soldiers involved in that event
come forward
and give many additional details we saw
the sons
and brothers of the journalists who were
killed in that event
come forward and give details
i saw the wife of the driver who was
killed
in in the van come forward and give
additional details so
that's what i expect to happen with this
material and to some degree
it is of such scope that it eclipses
the economic ability of the press
to go through it it's going to require
not just the press but
all interested parties to understand
this material
and that is why we have endeavoured to
put it into
a format that is easy
for people to go through and comprehend
did you say that you have only gone
through uh in detail two thousand of
these
seventy five thousand one thousand
documents well how do you square that
then with your
uh argument that this is a responsible
publication and that
you've done all the harm minimization
that you said you have
the documents are in many different
categories they are tagged with
different categories so we can see that
some categories
do not have the type of material that
would
as an example identify innocent
informers
well things are going pretty well so far
i mean um
i i suppose our greatest fear is that we
will
be too successful too fast and we won't
be able to do justice to the material
we're getting in
fast enough that's our greatest problem
at the
to moment that secrecy is an important
and unnecessary part of government
secrecy is sometimes perfectly
legitimate
for example your medical records
with your doctor are probably in all
likelihood
perfectly entitled through
confidentiality
but not always in some cases
but that is not true
so you make the choice
this is a matter about whether the
coercive power of the state
should be used to stop people sharing
information
who have no direct connection
to the source of the information so you
can't use the coercive power of the
state to stop people spreading rumors to
stop people discussing political life
and sophisticated us jurisprudence
understands that
and that is why you have things like the
first amendment which takes
the press outside the legislative
process because in the end it is the
communication of knowledge
which regulates the legislature
which creates the constitution
unfortunately we do not see any rivals
of blower sites
we did have a grand application into the
knight foundation to try and
give our technology to every news
organization in the world
so it submit you know so every newspaper
would have submit this material
uh to us using wikileaks technology
but that grant application was rejected
for political reasons after the
collateral motor video
do you see yourself accountable in
exactly the same way
three other major organizations
and secondly even those media
organizations
uh focus on uh driving a profit
what is the commercial arrangement
between themselves as wikileaks and
these three organizations who are
advertised there was no commercial
arrangement
ongoing in terms of disability no
commercial nature
at all we we
have been blessed uh over the past few
months of
receiving extensive report support by
the public
not by foundation support by journalists
and by human rights activists we have
raised
a million dollars from the general
public
as a result we have we are um
are unable to have a sort of fierce
independence
that larger organizations
uh find more difficult that said
of course we are also immediately
accountable to the public
because that is where all our money
comes from directly from the public
not from advertisers and not from
foundations
just apparently about what you want to
happen now in terms of
governance and uh prosecutors what do
you want to see
done with the information that you've
now posted and now it's out there in the
public domain what do you expect to see
happen and what do you want to have
well we would like to see this material
uh
the revelations that this material gives
be
taken seriously investigated
uh by governments and
new policies put in place as a result if
not
uh prosecutions of those people who have
committed abuses
this it's important to understand this
material doesn't just reveal abuses
this material describes
the past six years of war
every major attack that resulted
in someone being detained or someone
being killed
that tells you how the war is going
where this happened in what different
parts of afghanistan
what sort of weapon systems were used
which particular military units is there
a killer is there a killer unit
in the united states military because
there's been histories of that
you can find out using this data you can
create
a simple computer program we haven't
done it yet but any
one of your technical staff can create a
simple computer program
to add up the kills by unit
and get and find a top kill unit so that
that's an example of something can be
immediately extracted from this
so you can really see how the war in
afghanistan is going
and then compare that to government
statements and government policy
this is the raw material that ends up on
the big boards
on the war room there's even a field in
there d colour
which describes the color
that this material ends up and it's
displayed on
the big boards this is the raw
ingredients that lead to
pentagon statistics about civilian
casualties that lead to
graphs about how many insurgents are
killed
we only ever normally see those figures
in aggregate but now we have
all the events that are used to create
those figures and we can understand
whether those aggregate figures are in
fact accurate or are they distortions
in fact we can see in many cases where
we know
what's in this database and
we have press sourcing or afghan
government investigation
we can see the disparity between these
two so we can see
in fact the aggregate figures
are based on faulty data
yes
we see a lot of exculpatory language in
these reports
from a unit talking about
why it killed someone and why
why um a convoy is going on a road
car comes along goes to overtake they
shoot the driver
and so that unit then reports all the
things that it did
and you see we engaged in escalation of
force procedure and we told him to stop
and
but then what you what you look is
if if you look across these reports you
see an amazing number
of civilians killed by ricochets
so we fired a warning shot in the
ricochet
ended up killing this person i mean it's
it's just not credible
that that many people can be killed by
ricochets
so we we see that um
you know it's like a a policeman
investigating himself
filing his own report about an alleged
crime that he's meant to commit
alleged to have committed of course um
that sort of reportage
internal reportage is filled with errors
but that it is those initial reports
that then lead to investigations so we
can see
the field credible allegations of
coalition
forces causing civilian injuries that
field that was introduced about the same
time as general mcchrystal
took command we see
this unusually sorry um
applied to in an unrepresentative way
non-us forces so it's u.s forces talking
about the pole the u.s forces talking
about the french and that label gets
applied
when a unit reports its own activities
that label never gets applied
sometimes one u.s military unit will
apply it to the activities of another
u.s military unit
i mean this shouldn't be any surprise if
you have a basic understanding of how
human beings behave
um but it does show that it is a
hardship to manage
because the raw ingredients you need to
manage it the internal reporting
uh is not accurate
so what are you going to do
that's right so there's distortions
going up to the top
and then the top ties to push things
down
we want you to report all the civilian
kills
because what incentives is there for a
unit to report its own bad behavior
for the west is an utter lack of
understanding of the afghan people
where they are who they are what their
motives are what they're doing
a lot of what you've got here flows
they're from was it civilian countries
okay isn't that the central i agree but
what's your what's your question
do you draw the same central left
afghan people are many well there's many
diverse groups in afghanistan
having different economic bases
different language different
um clan affiliations uh and yet
u.s troops and british troops are
essentially culturally homogenous
and all go in there with the same sort
of culture but
there's many different regional cultures
in afghanistan i mean
i feel that i would be drawing myself
too much to
um uh
to agree with you although i can see
glimmers of that problem coming out of
the material but
the one thing is very clear to me i mean
it is one damn thing after another it is
it is war um but we don't normally see
war
uh through this material we do see what
war is like
the every at the everyday level as well
as the big events the whole lot you know
when we released this iraq video gates
secretary of defense gates said that it
was looking
at war through a straw and we only gave
40 minute video and somehow this lacked
context although we did give news
reports
about what happened on the day but this
if you like is the beginning the end and
the middle
uh this is the whole context
uh with some exceptions uh
of the afghan war and if anything
can give us some kind of intellectual
understanding
surely this is it whether whether it
engages people emotionally is another
matter i mean
to some degree that is the task of good
journalism is to turn
this raw material who when where
how how many uh into something
that emotionally engages people who can
apply levers on decision making
are you concerned though i mean
accepting the argument something is
well made and i think most of these
people expect that but are you concerned
that in the process of releasing this
information that actually
do more harm than good at least in some
areas
what about the relationship between
pakistan and afghanistan it's very
volatile
a lot of the information about isi
involvement comes from
mds and apparently you know biased or
potentially
yes in a way that could in fact
inflame at least an aspect thought by
the taliban but there was another
dimension in several dimensions
this is going to make that situation
worse
there is no perfect information um
but in the end the truth is all we have
right
but you have a more electrical response
to put information in a way that people
can
understand it and process it responsibly
there is well i think we have done that
i i think we have done that extremely
well i mean we have 14 pages in the
guardian just here
that's not a bad outcome right
journalistically
i mean what more could you do
what about the security of the trip's
imam goes down when we publish
this material the material is all seven
months old there doesn't seem to be any
there's no nothing about troop movements
no tactical
considerations in this material so
why of course i am not um
i would always think about that issue
before dismissing it out of hand
we have looked at it and it doesn't seem
to be anything significant
that said i mean the revelations of
abuses
by us and coalition forces
may cause afghanis to be upset and
rightly so
they should treat them better not
conceal
abuses that have been undertaken
undertaken
why does so much of this material that
you publish come from
us forces and not from other coalition
parts such as
the british actually we've published a
lot of material from the british
in fact the the ministry of defence put
in an
order to british telecom which uh
controls the gateway
for mod and told them to block all
connections going out to wikileaks
in an attempt to stop british forces
leaking us material
at least a stated attempt of course
what happened in practice is someone who
was responsible for
counterintelligence got some command
from a more senior person
saying look at that thing on wikileaks
shouldn't you do something and so they
wrote a letter to british telecom
instructing british telecom to make sure
that normal connections from inside the
mod couldn't
look at our web pages i mean the result
is that
those senior people who complain about
material that is on wikileaks are no
longer in a position to complain because
they can't read it
it's great no investigations because
they can't see the material that's there
we discovered this and using a proactive
foi that we
routinely do for sort of these sorts of
organizations that might
be trying to investigate our sources
yes the um the bnd
the german equivalent of the cia
uh their chief ernst
ullah wrote to us demanding the removal
of a document exposing corruption
in kosovo which included
information about cia behavior in kosovo
under under the threat that we would be
prosecuted under german law
would you respond yes all right
tell me more and tell me more uh
precisely what law
is it that we are going to be prosecuted
under
and eventually the b and d
decided that they didn't want to tell us
the law that we'd be prosecuted under
because of course there is no such law
let's please speak up a little bit
um
uh we won't comment on what we have not
yet released
um but that said
uh we can look at what happened in six
years
because you have a window of six years
from 2004 to 2010
and we don't see sudden dramatic shifts
when there is a change in policy as an
example by
the changes in policy when the crystal
came on board
i would find it very unlikely if there
were
any sudden dramatic shifts
in the behavior of
us forces all the isi
over the last seven months given that
there hasn't been
any significant change in the prior
five four years that would seem to be
unlikely to me if there would be any
inquiry
would you be willing to give the
original raw material
to get people an insight if
we have made available to the world
are 76
000 of these reports
in csv format xml format
sql format as a format you can load the
whole lot into google earth
and plot it by space and time
we have also released all the reports in
a browseable
interface if we actually get this vga
cable
cable working i'll be able to show you
um
that said of course we have not released
the uh
precise format that we obtained from our
source
my knowledge
now we'll